[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Stephen it's nice to see you thank you
for making the time today
pleased to be here and I was impressed
that
just before we started recording when I
fumbled and attempt to recall when it
was that we sat next to each other you
very quickly said 2011 wired Health
conference
and mention that you have an archive so
how do you search for something like
that
I keep an awful lot of stuff so I've uh
I've got all my email going back 30
years I have a habit of writing kind of
trip reports for myself whenever I go to
some event or something like that and I
have also scans of paper documents you
you weren't a paper document you're
you're more recent than a paper document
so to speak but I have scans of well
it's like a quarter million Pages or so
of paper documents but I generated in
the in the time in my life before I went
fully digital so to speak and I also
tend to record I record all the key
strokes I type and screen captures and
all kinds of things like that how do you
use the logging of the keystrokes I
don't usually you do not no usually I
don't occasionally I want to know you
know occasionally for example some
computable crash in some horrible way
and it'll be like oh I just lost a bunch
of stuff well no I didn't because I
haven't recorded right that was that was
the thing that caused me like 25 years
ago to start recording those there's one
crash and then I decided it's cheap to
just record everything like that and
occasionally I'll do things like oh I'm
using a new keyboard you know do I type
faster or slower on my new keyboard got
it you know those kinds of things and
you can track that type of thing easy to
answer that question if you have that
data
so it's one thing to record or ingest
information it's quite another structure
you're thinking and I in the process of
doing research for this conversation
came across
some discussion
on Reddit involving creating matrices so
I wanted to explore your use of matrices
for different projects and I'm just
going to read a very very short section
here which reads I actively avoid
thinking about things where I don't have
a matrix I don't like to have
disembodied ideas floating around which
is my current state of affairs so I'm
selfishly asking this of course when
something is important enough to me I
try to build a matrix for it could you
give an example of what such a matrix
might look like what I mean by that is
some kind of framework in which I'm
doing something so for example if I have
a small idea about molecular biology I
don't really have a good place to put
that idea if I'm doing a big project
about molecular biology where I'm
building up a whole structure then I
have a place to put that so it's it's
that kind of thing and you know I've
been lucky enough you know the the main
my my main life work is building our
computational language welcome language
which is this language that's supposed
to represent sort of everything in the
world computationally so a large number
of ideas that I have about how to
represent things computationally can
wind up in The Matrix which is the world
from language similarly I found you know
for example writing my blog like kind of
writings thing that's another kind of
Matrix into which I can put you know
when I do kind of historical studies of
things I'll write a piece about that
historical study and that's a place to
put it but you know when it's when it's
sort of too small a thing I just don't
have a place to put it and it tends to
die on the vine you know I was since
you're asking about this I've I've just
been exposing myself to a very bizarre
experience which is I've just been
finishing a project that I started 50
years ago wow okay and in the process of
doing this so I I something that I
started I got interested in when I was
12 years old it's a question about
physics and about the second row of
thermodynamics and why sort of
Randomness gets generated in the world
and so on and I've made various pieces
of progress on this question over the
years but finally now with a bunch of
the things that we've done recently in
understanding fundamental Theory of
physics I think I can actually really
nail this question so I I've written the
whole thing about kind of the the
scientific answer to that question but I
thought I should write a piece kind of
describing my 50-year journey of trying
to answer this question and so that got
me back into I'm looking at all my
calendars from 1983 and and I'm looking
at all of these paper documents that I
have scanned and so on it's a very
interesting experience going back and
seeing you know what mattered from 1983
and what didn't how did I get to the
things that were important in the end
how did those come to be what were the
what were the kinds of steps that I had
to go through one of the things I really
noticed really striking to me is there's
often often a large amount of time in
which I was building some conceptual
framework for something sometimes I had
clues about how that framework should
work I didn't even recognize the clues
just didn't understand it finally
there's sort of very slow process I
build the central actual framework and
then I get some other clue I do some
other computer experiments something
else happens and then literally I can
trace because I have all the you know
file creation dates all this kind of
thing I can trace you know it was 15
minutes from the time when I saw this to
the time when I started writing this and
and so on and it's it's really
remarkable how much you know years can
go by that one sort of slowly building
up the kind of conceptual framework
needed and then then it's often very
sudden to kind of take the next step
that was a kind of a striking thing to
me so I want to ask a few follow-up
questions about conceptual Frameworks
and perhaps just uh request an example
of what such a conceptual framework
might look like for people listening in
for me frankly but before we get to that
putting together
a blog post or an article that
Chronicles your search for answers or
exploration of these open questions is
quite an undertaking reviewing calendars
from 1983 and so on I would imagine
requires a good amount of time
why do you do it or is it the reward in
the process of writing is it is it
something gratifying in the process of
writing are you hoping to impart
something to those who read this piece
why do that that's a good question I was
wondering at myself I thought it would
be really easy but it wasn't quite so
easy no I have done quite a lot of kind
of historical biography usually of other
people
I find it you know when I'm really
trying to understand an idea I need to
know where that idea came from so for
example the things I'm doing right now
on the second world thermodynamics thing
second law of Thermodynamics was
developed in the 1860s
I think people took a wrong turn
sometime shortly thereafter so I think
the thing that I've now figured out is a
little different from what people had
figured out at that time and so when I'm
saying I think they took a wrong turn I
really want to know how did they come to
take that wrong turn and so that's my
next project for the next week or so is
is going back and I've collected the
material for it I can't get to go back
and and read all the original kind of
sources of how people came to think
about those things but I don't feel
confident that I know what was going on
until I can kind of trace this person
took that move because they thought this
and they understood that and so on and I
thought for myself I was mostly well a
bit curious I thought it was sort of an
interesting story it's a very rare case
in kind of History of Science but when
actually has really precise detailed
data on how some idea got developed and
so I thought kind of an interesting
example of essentially computational
history you know one thinks about
computational X for all X this is
computational history and it's kind of
like what can you do in computational
history what kinds of things
can you kind of expose in computational
history the other thing that's
interesting to me is when I go back and
think about things that I did or figured
out you know 40 years ago let's say
I sort of lived through it but then when
I look back I realized there were
threads that could be joined that I
absolutely did not see at the time so
you know give you an example I was
working on these simple programs what do
simple programs do the big surprise was
even very simple programs can do very
complicated things that was something I
didn't expect it was kind of a violation
of my intuition took me a couple of
years to kind of come to terms with the
fact that that was possible
same time several have actually sort of
top mathematicians who the sort of
friends of mine were trying to work on
sort of the things that I had uncovered
they said let's go do math on these
things let's figure out more stuff about
them and they worked for a while I just
found a bunch of their notes actually
from going through these things from
1984 and so on and they did a bunch of
very sort of uh sophisticated math and
they couldn't figure out anything
and what I realized is you know at the
time I was just like okay well I'm
figuring out my things their methods
didn't happen to work so what
what I then realized just now is the big
innovation of mine was realizing that
the fact that they couldn't figure out
anything was itself a super interesting
fact so in other words there's this
phenomenon I call computational
irreducibility which is basically kind
of the big picture of why they couldn't
figure out anything else so you know
usually you say you say I know the rules
by which some system operates so then
you might say okay great I've got it
nailed I know everything about what's
going to happen in that system
well that's not true because if the
rules Define some computation it's to
know what the system does you have to
you can find out by running the
computation the question is can you
outrun that computation can you say Okay
system you went through a million steps
of that computation but I don't need to
do that I'm smarter than the system I
can just say the answer is 42 or
something
what computational irreducibility tells
you is that in general you are stuck
kind of having to follow each step in
the in the evolution of the system and
that's a really important fact about
science it's kind of a way in which
science explains from within science
that science has questions that it can't
readily answer and the thing that I
realized only you know I don't know what
35 years after the fact is that in a
sense if I had an achievement
intellectual achievement in that whole
process it was realizing that the fact
that one had gotten stuck was itself the
most important thing to know not oh we
got stuck let's give up but the fact
that one got stuck meant that there was
sort of a paradigmatic change that had
to be made in the way that you think
about these kinds of questions in
science so that's an example that for me
is quite useful to go back and and see
what really happened there what was
really important there which I had not
realized at the time makes me think a
bit of the the Sherlock Holmes The Case
of the dog that didn't bark in the night
but
the term that I'd love for you just to
elaborate on a little bit and I
apologize this is going to be a muggle
question but for people who are
non-technical I'll put myself in that
audience when you say for instance
computational history or computational X
how should someone who may have fear
around the term computational think of
that term computational history as an
example
we humans like to sort of come up with
abstract formal ways to describe things
language itself is an example of that
you know we we see things out and there
in the world and we say that's a tree
that's a dog you know that's whatever
the fact that we're able to sort of
symbolically describe these things in
the world there are many different kinds
of dogs in many different details but we
just say it's a dog that's a way of kind
of organizing the things that we see in
that case just using natural language
they've been in the in in sort of
History a variety of kinds of
organizational approaches Logic for
example was one from you know Antiquity
then mathematics is another kind of
organizational approach to say this is
how you kind of structure the way that
you talk about the world as far as I'm
concerned the importance of computation
is it's another way to structure how you
talk about the world and a big part of
what I've spent my life doing is
building this kind of computational
language which provides sort of a
precise way to take something like like
I don't know
some description of some piece of food
or some description of some position on
the earth or whatever else and represent
those things computationally in a sort
of precise way that has the feature that
well a human could read it and say I
know what that means but also we have
the extra sort of Boost from the fact
that a computer can read it too and then
the computer can kind of help us to get
further with that so I mean in a sense
you know one of the big things that we
as a species you know big achievement is
human language you know you can take
sort of things about the world and
describe them in a sort of somewhat
precise abstract way I see computational
languages being kind of another level in
that Evolution except that we get to
kind of share the burden of seeing what
happens not just with other humans but
with computers and for me that's kind of
the the big thing is is describing the
world computationally now when I talk
about you know simple programs and and
those those kinds of things what I tend
to mean is kind of a meta model of the
world so there are models of actual
trees and dogs and trajectories on the
earth and and things like this and then
there are sort of how do you break that
down to something sort of even more
primitive so then what you end up with
are these sets of rules that say well
you could describe what they are about
in many different ways but for example
one type that I've studied a lot the
technical name is cellular automata and
the typical sort of setup is you have a
row of cells just and each cell can be
either black or white let's say and then
the computational rule is you look at
every cell and you say what is the color
of that cell and its two neighbors let's
say based on that you say okay I'm going
to change the color of the cell to be
you know white or to be black or
whatever you just keep running that rule
over and over again the big surprises
and this is the thing I finally
discovered in around 1984 the big
surprise is that even with a rule that
simple you can just start it off with
one black dot and it makes this
incredibly complicated pattern a pattern
so complicated that if you were to just
look at you know a piece of the pattern
and say is this random or is there some
some regularity to it you would just say
it looks completely random to me even
though the rule that made it is this
very very simple rule that you you can
easily describe or write down or feed to
a computer or whatever else so so kind
of for me this notion of computation is
kind of having this way to kind of
structure the way that you talk about
the world and then there's this kind of
meta modeling of that which is to say
what are the very simplest elements of
that computational process and then talk
about what what one can do with those I
mean I think a good analogy perhaps for
for sort of the computational
description of the world is comes from
sort of the mathematical notation that
one uses to talk about mathematics I
mean it's sort of an interesting
Evolution that that um if you look at
mathematics done in Antiquity and things
like that people didn't have a symbol
for plus they just used words and then
sometime around 500 years ago people
started inventing you know a plus sign
an equal sign things like this and it's
when that sort of streamlining of the
way to talk about math came online
that's where math really took off and
algebra gun indented and then calculus
and then we have this whole sort of
mathematical approach to science that
was able to be done and you know I guess
my my own sort of personal last 40 Years
of effort has been to sort of try to
make a computational notation for
talking about the world that is kind of
a a parallel for computation of what
mathematical notation is for kind of the
mathematical way of talking about the
world
I have a question about natural
languages and I don't think I'm
misquoting but feel free to fact check
this
you are so deeply aware of and able to
work with language in in multiple I
would say dimensions
I did read at one point you were
considering a job with CERN and I
believe I read that you said you'd
practice French but had never built up
the nerve to use it or something along
those lines and I don't know if that was
a tongue-in-cheek comment no no that's
from ancient times but you know I went
to fancy schools in England when I was
growing up and I I learned three
languages Latin Greek and French okay
you don't get to speak Latin or Greek
ancient Greek or at least not in most
places
but French you could in principle speak
and you know I can I can read like
scientific French pretty fluently but if
you say you know if I'm in France and
I'm like can I order that piece of food
or something I no way I can't do that
it's one of these things I should get
over it one day because I think I you
know I have the vocabulary knowledge I
think and all that I just have never
really gotten into that you know I've
been very deeply involved in
computational language I've not been
deeply I've been interested in human
language but I'm not from the point of
view of sort of the the practice of
learning learning lots of human
languages it's one of those skills where
I'm kind of like I could have put a lot
of effort into it but it's like
automatic translation is now going to
the point where the many kinds of things
not so important anymore just like I
could have been a champion map reader
and you know I'm glad I didn't put huge
effort into that because I just use a
GPS now yeah that's true I suppose I am
the opposite in the sense that I've
spent a lot of time on natural languages
in part because I derive so much
pleasure
and I think the sort of cognitive uh
exercise from pursuing it but looking at
the progression say in Google Translate
from my last trip to Japan which was
pre-covered to just about six weeks ago
it is astonishing
how how much it has improved and
unfortunately I already speak read and
write Japanese reasonably well because I
want there's an exchange student when I
was 15 but the extent to which someone
can now
use their voice pretty synchronously to
communicate with someone with automatic
translation is remarkable where do you
see that
or how do you see that developing say in
the in the next
a handful of years are in the near term
I mean this is something I would imagine
you probably have
a view on how do you think we'll be
using this type of Technology
in the next call it five years
you know I think one of the things that
it really
kind of drills into is the kind of the
whole question of can you actually
express the same thoughts in different
human languages yeah and that's a kind
of a deep issue and I think what we
realize is that language is one kind of
representation of kind of organized
human thoughts and the
in a sense it is a kind of societal
construction of you know we all kind of
know what a chair is so when we use the
word chair we kind of know what each
other is talking about yeah but if you
have a language that comes from a place
where the environment the culture is
very different you'll end up with words
where they're really just quotes isn't a
translation for that word yeah because
there just isn't this sort of shared
cultural understanding of what one's
talking about there so I think the thing
that will be pretty interesting to see
is you know as we see kind of the
tightening up of the kind of the
structural aspects of translation at
what point do we really realize you know
in that culture there are thoughts that
we just don't have in in some other
culture and that's something you know as
you start generalizing that it's kind of
like okay how do we communicate with
sort of the alien intelligences you know
how do you communicate with cats and
dogs how do you communicate with AIS
things like this these are all kind of
examples of of alien intelligences with
which we share certain kinds of things
you know we share some emotional
responses with pets and things like this
but we don't share probably some sort of
deep philosophical convictions and so on
yeah and so you know it's sort of
interesting to see how this process of
translation can work and sort of how far
out can you translate things and I guess
for for computers you know the thing
I've been most involved in is how do you
go from the things we think about in our
minds to the things that we can
represent for a computer
computers can compute all kinds of
things many of the things they can
compute we humans don't at least
currently care about
there's a certain small set of possible
things computers can do that are things
that relate to the things that we humans
in the current state of our civilization
and so on have decided we care about and
so sort of an interesting question to
understand kind of to what extent we can
translate the things we we think we care
about into something which can be
represented computationally that comes
back again and I suppose I suppose after
one spent one's life working on
something everything somehow relates to
these questions like how do you make
this kind of computational language to
represent kind of human thoughts in a
computational way now now you know when
you talk about natural language
translation and so on what we've done
you know when we make
uh Wolfman Alpha system and intelligent
assistant uses of that and so on what
it's doing is it's taking a natural
language question like uh you know
what's the population of India divided
by China in 1960 or something and it's
taking that and it is turning that into
a precise kind of computational question
precise sort of symbolic representation
that we can then compute the answer from
but whatever poetry there might have
been in that question like you know can
you tell me the population of the some
poetic name for some country and some
other thing we Crush all the Poetry out
of that we're just turning it into so
what is the precise computational
representation that is good computer
speak so to speak
whereas it could have been that the the
very sort of uh appreciative way that
somebody describes some country in some
translated into some other human
language that notion of appreciation
would have been the most important part
of that sort of thing that one's asking
but you know for the computer it says I
don't care about that I'm just you know
I'm just here to provide a symbolic
representation and give the answer so to
speak yeah I think the thing to
understand about translation ultimately
is the destination mind
isn't built the same way the source mind
is necessarily built yeah and so that
there may just be no way to change that
now you know you can see that if you
imagine imagine you have two machine
learning neural net systems and they've
both been trained how to tell cats from
dogs for example
the internal methods by which they will
do it will typically be quite different
they will have gone you know the details
of of how they will have reacted to that
training will be quite different and so
there isn't sort of a direct translation
okay
you know system a does it this way
inside it's most important thing is that
the tail
has this form or something like this you
know so there isn't this kind of direct
internal translation just as for humans
you know even if we could do you know
brain to brain transfer of thoughts it's
not really going to work just like
when you have two machine Learning
Systems the details of how they learn
things inside will be different yeah and
that sort of thought experiment so to
speak about direct transfer of thoughts
that sort of also applies that the thing
that is the the robust transfer of
thoughts is basically language the
thoughts themselves are not directly
transferable but we package them into
language which is this kind of formal
representation of thoughts that we can
transfer from one mind to another so to
speak
that's my way of thinking about that at
least yeah this underscore is I think
part of the appeal for me in learning
these languages even when they really
have very little utility so I was just
studying Romanian which has very limited
use
and a part of the fascination is as
you're mentioning these these Concepts
or labels
that take the form of language
even if the translations of literal
translation can be conveyed to the
Target mind
the Nuance can be much more challenging
to convey
and I find exploring the language as a
way to better understand the thinking of
a Target population whether Japanese or
Romanian to be a lot of fun because for
instance in Japanese
there are at least 40 or 50 ways to say
no but they might take the form of well
that's very difficult or maybe that's
possible let me ask Mr Takahashi and
those all mean no
but the the translation won't
necessarily convey that and also
thinking about
and I'll stop my mini Ted Talk here in a
second but
the structure of the language let's just
say something as simple as as subject
verb object I eat the apple versus I the
Apple eat which you would find in
Japanese and then in German you would
find it but only in certain cases where
it's a relative clause and all of that
I think represents often represents
fundamental differences in how people
process reality
so I I really enjoy it now
let me ask you a question about the type
of sort of scientific forensic
analysis that you've done where you're
looking at how someone took a left turn
in say
thermodynamics at some point in time I
have not read this book of yours idea
makers so compilation of essays how did
you choose the players on the field for
this how did you choose the people you
included
oh it was always opportunistic I'm
afraid some of it was somebody died and
I knew them and I wanted to write an
obituary post others were somebody was
having a big anniversary and there was a
big sort of shindig associated with that
so rather opportunistically but it
happened to cover a rather nice
collection of different types of types
of folks from you know from dick Feynman
and Steve Jobs who are both people I
knew to uh people like Ada Lovelace and
ramanujan who are people who you know
died long before I was born
dick Feynman I'd love to if you would
indulge me just to tell me a bit of your
experience with dick Feynman so I
own the set of Encyclopedia Britannica
that he bought when he was I think 43
years old I ended up buying it on my
43rd birthday as a reminder to never
stop
searching and learning that's cool and I
I do have a few diagrams of his as well
which I prize and I wish I knew more
physics I really enjoyed it when I was
younger I did not pursue it to an
advanced level at all so I really wish I
could appreciate his genius in a higher
Fidelity way but what was it like to
spend time with him and how did you know
him what was he like in person I met him
when I was 18 and he was 60. okay yeah
and he would always say you know I was
as quick as you were but now I'm three
times older
so he could be quite competitive in
those kinds of things but um
you know the thing that I
liked about him
like whenever I see it is he just would
think about anything it's like you know
the thinking apparatus is engaged and
will stay engaged whatever the topic so
to speak
and he liked kind of drilling down to
really get what is the real Point what's
the what's the essence of what's going
on and you know sometimes he would play
a little trick on the world which was
one of the things he was really good at
was calculating things by hand he used
computers a little bit
but mostly hand calculation complicated
math these kinds of things and so he
would do you know have some question he
would do all this complicated math to
work out the answer
then you get this answer and then he
would think well how can I have figured
out that answer by just some intuitive
argument without having to go through
all the complicated math I think he
thought I remember talking to him about
this he thought that you know everybody
can do the complicated math but it's
really impressive if you can figure this
out by intuition and so he would then
figure out this into Advance throw away
the math tell people only the intuition
and so people were you know there's some
Fields where where he did that and
people are like we don't know how an
earth he figured this out and you know
people have been trying to reverse
engineer the math for years but that was
that was one of his little sort of
tricks on the world so to speak
that's incredible intellectual sleight
of hand would ramanujan this is someone
I know even less about
personify the intuition that Feynman was
referring to on some level or with the
well Ramadan is a different kind of
story so ramanu John was a kind of
slightly you know decently educated kind
of person just hanging out in India and
producing remarkable mathematical
results ramanujan like Feynman was a
very good calculator
and it really confused the
mathematicians because he would say I've
got this amazing formula for pi nobody's
ever seen anything like it and he'd say
here it is and and then when he started
corresponding with mathematicians in
England in 1913 or whatever they were
like how did you prove this how do you
know this
and eventually he got so fed up I think
that he told them well the the goddess
so and so told it to me in a dream okay
but the truth of it was he was a really
good calculator and so he just worked
out you know this particular series is
the same as Pi to this number of decimal
places and he had good enough
mathematical intuition to say and it's
just going to be correct it's not just
going to be an approximation it's going
to be exactly right occasionally that
intuition failed him he had a result
about prime numbers for example where he
had done many many cases and it looked
like it was true turns out the result
isn't true but the first exception is at
10 to the 10 to the 100 or something you
know some huge place which which he
couldn't reach with calculation so in a
sense he was he was kind of I think a
great experimental mathematician had he
used computers he would have you know
had a whole different set of things he
could have discovered but even with
himself as the computer so to speak he
was discovering all kinds of things and
literally the mathematicians of the time
had never seen anything like it and so
for them it just seemed to be this kind
of magical thing where he was just
pulling formulas from nothing a bit like
dick Feynman he was often pulling
formulas from a lot of hard work of
computation
and you know I remember when when I was
younger I happened to start using
computers to do physics sort of very
early on when I was a teenager and so on
and for some reason you know the tools
existed but to be able to do some
mathematical computations by computer
but people weren't using them one of the
experiences that I had when I was kind
of a kid
was
I kind of discovered the fact that
computers can be really powerful for
doing science and so on when I was kind
of 13 14 15 years old and I started
using them to do that and I started
being able to derive all kinds of
complicated mathematical formulas and so
on by computer for whatever crazy reason
other people just weren't doing that and
so I could write physics papers where I
would have these very elaborate formulas
that I derived and so on and people were
like you must be amazingly good at doing
all this calculational stuff and it's
like well no actually I'm actually
pretty bad at it but you know me with a
computer we're pretty good but they
didn't really understand the fact that
that was a thing back in those days so
yeah I've seen this kind of interesting
phenomenon when you use tools
that you know where you don't
necessarily but people don't necessarily
even understand that those tools exist
yeah it kind of has some interesting
consequences the attribution I'm gonna
skip but what was it any sufficiently
advanced form of Technologies
indistinguishable from Magic something
like that I can't remember yeah I think
maybe an officy clock yeah I think that
sounds like Arthur C Clarke
I've spent a lot of my kind of
scientific effort
getting intuition from doing computer
experiments and you know in another age
I would have been there with test tubes
and other things doing physical
experiments thank goodness I can get
away with doing computer experiments
because it's a lot better for me so to
speak but uh you know you do these
experiments and there's a certain art to
doing a good computer experiment but you
can discover things that you never
thought were there and they kind of
inform your intuition and allow you to
build things up and it's kind of like
this thing that comes from nowhere
because it's just coming from from not
the natural world but kind of the
computational world you're just you know
turning over this rock in the
computational world and suddenly you
discover that there's this whole whole
crazy thing going on underneath it so to
speak I would love to pose a question
that was posed at a group dinner I
attended not too long ago and it's
related to
what the moderator called heresies and
the heresy in this context was something
that the people in this small group
about six to eight people would disagree
with you about and these were a lot of
technical folks and I think each person
in the group could have put out many
things they believed that the broader
population would disagree with them
about but are there any particular
beliefs that you have or scientific
insights computational insights
this could be related to the physics
project
could be related to other things things
you believe that you have high
conviction in that many people would
disagree with you on now but let's just
say hopefully 10 years from now looking
back they would say ah yes that was
actually in fact had some grounds to it
does anything come to mind I mean
there's several but this one example of
a big one but this one is kind of the
the resistance is crumbling rapidly so
maybe it doesn't it doesn't quite count
as well but I think it would still be
the case that uh if you pull
let's say physicists
the resistance would not have completely
crumbled so and that's the question of
what is space
and is space made of anything
so go back let's say 120 years
people said what's water made of water
isn't made of anything water is just a
fluid that flows in the way it flows
turns out what became clear in the late
19th century is actually water is made
of something people had guessed it much
earlier it's made of molecules
so the question now is what is space
made of this this thing that we kind of
move around in is it just
a a thing where we get to place
something wherever we want or does it
have an inner structure and I've been
pretty sure for quite a while that space
has kind of an inner structure it's just
made of these discrete sort of uh atoms
of existence kind of you can think of in
the case of space atoms of space and all
that one can say is how these atoms of
space are connected to other ones so
there's this kind of giant Network that
defines the structure of space and
that's what space ultimately is and
everything that exists in the universe
is a feature of the way those
connections work and the underlying
structure of space that's kind of like
if you have a fluid there's a bunch of
these molecules bouncing around but
let's say you just look at little Vortex
a little Eddy on the surface of the
fluid little Whirlpool type thing there
is a we can say there's a Whirlpool you
can see it go by and we can talk about
it and so on but ultimately it's just
made of a bunch of molecules moving in a
particular organized kind of fashion and
it's my strong belief that sort of
everything we know in the universe all
the electrons and photons and the things
we that get made up of those they're all
just sort of things like Eddies in the
structure of this giant Network that is
the sort of underlying data structure of
the universe and the underlying thing
that space is made of where would Dark
Matter fit into this be vetoed by this
be compatible or incompatible
it's kind of a detail yeah
the bigger picture
is something which is a a more
embarrassing feature of current physics
so you know dark matter is the rotations
of galaxies look like there's more stuff
inside the Galaxy than you can account
for by looking at the luminous stars and
so on
but there's a bigger embarrassment which
is that in Quantum field Theory the kind
of standard theory of the way sort of
small scale stuff happens in physics
there is this phenomenon called zero
point fluctuations and they're an
infinite collection of zero point
fluctuations in the universe that are
associated with energy that has a
gravitational effect that would roll the
universe up into a tiny ball you know
that is not what we see we see a
Universe that's a big universe not the
universe that's just rolled up into a
tiny ball and so that's kind of the in
terms of sort of missing energy that is
a much bigger by a factor of uh a
hundred dollars of magnitude or more
that's a bigger problem so to speak than
the Dark Matter problem these are all
kind of features of there's aspects of
the universe where there's energy but
where the energy doesn't seem to have
the effect that we would expect to have
we don't know where the energy is coming
from and so on one feature of of our
sort of model of physics is that the the
very processes that are leading to those
vacuum fluctuations and so on those are
the processes that knit together the
structure of space so in the usual
Theory it's like there's space and
that's a thing and then there's all this
matter that is doing all these weird
Quantum fluctuations in space and that
matter should have more of an effect on
space but in our models those sort of
quantum flat situation like things those
are what make space and so it's kind of
not surprising and the math works out
this way that the thing that makes space
doesn't itself have the effect on Space
of doing something like curling the
universe up into a tiny ball so that's a
that's an example of how something like
that works out in in our kind of model
physics
I do have a question about time which
I'll get to in a second but
any other heresies that would be on the
short list of things that come to mind
here's another one it's a little bit
more detailed
so what's happened is as a result of the
physics project we have come to
understand
a kind of different paradigmatic way of
thinking about a bunch of things and so
there are a bunch of fields that you can
then apply this new paradigmatic way of
thinking too and start to make sort of
foundational changes in those fields
I'll mention another thing which I I
don't know how much of a heresy this is
but but in in physics the two big
theories of physics well they're really
three big theories of 20th century
physics general relativity Einstein's
theory of gravity quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics which is what
brings us things like the second order
of thermodynamics the law of entropy
increase and so on that's the theory of
heat so to speak so those are those are
the three big theories of 20th century
physics
one of the things that I think is just
super amazingly cool is it's turned out
that all three of those theories are
basically come from the same place
they're all in a sense versions of the
same statement they're all in some sense
the same Theory which to me is is really
remarkable and in fact one of the things
that has just become clear to me now is
that the people have thought well okay
so statistical mechanics is about when
you put lots of molecules together what
do they typically do so for example you
can have molecules that make a gas and
you say there are certain gas laws that
determine the pressure and volume of the
gas and so on these are typical things
that happen when you just throw a bunch
of molecules all together that's what
statistical mechanics is about
and people have believed that the sort
of the the most significant thing in
statistical mechanics the second row of
thermodynamics which is the law that
says things tend to get more random when
you sort of have mechanical work that's
doing things eventually that's
dissipated as heat and once it's heat
that's kind of microscopic motion of
molecules you never get back that
large-scale mechanical motion it's
turned into heat it's random you don't
get anything back from it that's that's
some so people have believed that it's
sort of possible to quote derive the
second orthon amics in some kind of
almost mathematical way you don't really
need to know physics to be able to
derive that principle that things tend
to for example go from mechanical work
to heat but people have believed that
general relativity and quantum mechanics
are both kind of wheel in features of
our universe they're both things where
you could have made a universe that
didn't have one of those things they're
just things where it happened to be that
way
what has become clear from our physics
project is that all three of these
theories sort of come from the same
place and they're all as derivable as
each other and they're all derivable in
a really
interesting way they're all derivable
ultimately from this strange thing we
call the rouliad which is this limit of
all possible computations the kind of
entangled limit of all possible
computations and what turns out to
happen is all three of those theories
are the result of observers like us
sampling this rouliad object and what
matters is that that we have certain
attributes as observers for example we
are computationally bounded we can only
fit a limited amount of sort of
computational stuff into our minds we
can't describe oh here's where every
atom in the universe went in Our Minds
The Narrative that we have for
describing the universe is far away from
let's describe where every atom went
we're just talking about this much more
sort of uh filtered versions of what's
going on in the universe that turns out
to be one of the important things the
other one is that we believe we are
persistent in time
so in other words even though at every
moment we are made from different atoms
of space we are being the atoms of space
that we were at one moment are being
destroyed new ones are being created and
so on despite that we believe that we
are persistent in time it's kind of like
the little Eddy on the water the
molecules that make that Eddy it's
different molecules at every moment in
time yet there is a definite thing which
if the Eddie was had a mind so to speak
it could think it is persistent in time
so those two features that our minds are
computationally bounded and we believe
we are persistent in time those two
features determine kind of how we sample
this ruliad thing which is kind of the
ultimate limit of all possible processes
and the sampling that we get to do is
one that gives us those three features
those three big theories of 20th century
physics how do you spell really odd
r-u-l-i-a-d oh I got it look at that
incredible now it's is there a lay
explanation or exploration of the really
ad that isn't completely corrupted that
one like myself might Digest
the first thing to think about is
a little bit of a story that gets to it
um
you know one of the things I've long
been interested in is is there a simple
rule from which where you just run that
rule long enough and you'll get
everything that happens in the universe
so in other words I was talking before
about how you know simple computational
rules you run them they do really
complicated things right sort of the
most complicated thing we know about is
the whole universe so could we find a
rule are we just write down this Rule
and you know we could run it long enough
it would just make the whole universe
okay so then you start thinking well
let's
imagine that we had that rule let's
imagine that we'd found that right let
me let me go actually one one other
place first which is how quantum
mechanics works so In classical
mechanics
you have laws that describe sort of how
things move or what happens in in the
world so uh you know there might be
something that says I throw a ball with
a certain velocity it will move in a
certain trajectory definite answer and
by classical you mean Newtonian in this
case yes got it actually relativistic
physics works the same way got it okay
that's that's sort of the distinction
between classical as in not Quantum and
Quantum okay so this was kind of the the
dividing line is kind of around 1920.
it's about 100 years old and so in the
quantum view of the world it isn't the
case that definite things happen instead
the Quantum View is there are many paths
that get followed that was kind of a a
dick Feynman idea that this idea of path
integrals and and following many Quantum
paths but the the kind of the notion
is that in quantum mechanics lots of
different things happen the ball goes on
many different possible trajectories we
as observers of what happened we get to
sample across those possibilities and
just get to say oh there was a certain
probability that this would happen
there's a certain probability that would
happen so that's kind of the the
traditional view of quantum mechanics
so in our models
you have this giant graph that
represents this giant Network that
represents the structure of the universe
and it's continually being re Rewritten
According to some rule what turns out to
happen is there are many different
possible rewrites that could occur those
different possible rewrites give you
these different Paths of History they
give you essentially different different
threads of time so to speak different
different possible things that could
happen in the universe those those
threads of History they sometimes they
Branch because two different things
could happen next sometimes they merge
because two things end up producing
essentially the same universe so you end
up with this whole complicated structure
of branching and merging of possible
histories for the universe so now the
question is how do we perceive what's
going on in that universe and why do we
not see the universe as this thing where
it's branching all over the place and
you know how can we tell what's
happening well the thing we have to
realize is that we ourselves are
embedded in this branching universe so
our minds are branching just like
everything else in the universe is
branching so it turns out sort of the
core question of of sort of how one
person receives quantum mechanics says
how does a branching mind perceive a
branching universe
and so then this thing that I mentioned
that's a feature of us is we believe
that we are persistent in time
and so we even though at some in some
sort of external God's eye view so to
speak the universe is branching like
crazy we we believe that our minds are
going through a single thread of
experience and so that means as we
impose that belief on what's actually
going on in the universe we sort of
conflate lots of different paths that
from the outside would look like the
universe is doing different things but
we so know actually those are all in
some sense the same thing because that's
what we have to believe in order to have
this conceit that we have a definite
threat of experience and so that process
is kind of what drives kind of the
understanding of how quantum mechanics
works and actually returning to Dick
Feynman again he always used to say that
having worked his whole life on quantum
mechanics he always was very fond of
saying nobody understands quantum
mechanics and he's very um and I've
talked to him for ages and ages about
that and and um and I I wish he was
still around because I think I can
finally say I think I actually
understand quantum mechanics and it's
it's just you know this idea of the
branching mind perceiving the branching
Universe I hadn't seen that coming at
all and it's a kind of a a bizarre idea
that uh that turns out I think to sort
of unlock how that works but okay so in
quantum mechanics we have all these
different possible possible things that
could happen in the universe which to us
get conflated together into a definite
kind of path
well
so okay so let's say we've got this
model and we we say we find this Rule
and this rule represents everything the
universe does so then we we might
imagine this day or you've got this rule
comes out of our computer we've done
some search and we have you know rule
number 713 is our universe
okay so for a long time I was just
really kind of
uncomfortable with that idea because
let's say we're Universe 713 the next
question is why did we get number 713
why didn't we get number seven trillion
whatever why this one and you know one
of the big lessons of science over the
last 500 years is kind of the Copernicus
lesson we're not very special you know
we might have thought the Earth was the
center of the universe we might have
thought these kinds of things but it
isn't true we're just sort of a on a
random Planet somewhere in this random
sort of space of that makes up the
universe so the even the idea that our
rule is a simple rule as opposed to an
incredibly complicated rule seems very
anti-copene and so this this really
bothered me for a long time and I
realized actually it's something even
more bizarre maybe going on which is
maybe the universe is not picking any
particular rule it's running all
possible rules and so what the rouliad
is is this computational process that
runs all possible rules so imagine you
had all possible computers and you start
them off from all possible starting
points and you run them all so you might
say how could that do anything
interesting the critical point is that
sometimes those computers will end up
making the same thing so in other words
two different computers might end up
having being producing something which
is the same has has the same structure
and so when you might say Well they're
just all going to do their independent
things well they don't do independent
things because they're all these
equivalences between things that they do
and so you end up building up this Rich
structure and that structure you build
up is what we call the rulihad it's the
entangled limit of all possible
computations and and what's really kind
of interesting about it is there's only
one of it and it is a necessary object
in other words as soon as you define
that you're talking about the notion of
computation as soon as you kind of
Define your terms you have the rouliad
it isn't it's not the case that it's
like oh it so happens that this feature
of the world is this way it is as
inevitable as once you've defined what
integers are and what plus signs are and
so on two plus two equals four there's
no way of getting out of that it's not
something that is a a random fact about
the world that humans happen to you know
have
two eyes and a nose type thing which
which might be seen to be sort of more
coincidental it's something that is a
necessary feature from the kind of
formal structure of what you've set up
so the rouliad is this kind of necessary
object and now the thing which is kind
of interesting is okay so you have this
object that is this limit of all
possible computations so how do we
experience that
well we are also part of that object so
it's the same kind of a story as the
branching mind perceiving the branching
Universe except an even more abstracted
version of that it's how do we as pieces
of as elements inside this rouliad
perceive the whole rouliad
so one of the things one starts talking
about is this notion of what we call
rule space which is the space of kind of
possible different views of how the
universe works so we might say
we've got one view of the universe oh it
works this way it follows this Rule and
then some other person alien whatever
says no no you're quite wrong the
universe really works according to this
other rule instead
now the reason the what what nets all of
that together is a kind of a technical
fact that's been known for about 100
years which is this idea of universal
computation you might have thought that
you know if you wanted to have a
computer that was a word processor you'd
buy a word processing computer you won't
have a spreadsheet computer you buy a
spreadsheet computer but the big fact
that emerged in the 1920s and 1930s is
that you can have a single sort of
Hardware object it wasn't put to
practice until the 1940s and 50s but you
can have the single Hardware object that
can just be programmed to be a word
processor be a spreadsheet whatever and
it's kind of the same thing with the
universe that you can attribute
different rules to the operation of the
universe but they're interconvertible in
the same way as your computer can be
made to run a spreadsheet rather than a
word processor so to speak so one of the
things that I really kind of like about
this is there's this notion of where are
you in rural space
what kind of mode of description of
what's going on in the world do you have
and you can imagine that every different
mind is at a different place in rural
space so
the fact that
you and I have different internal models
of the world is a statement of the fact
that we are some distance apart in rural
space and so what you realize is the you
know as we think about the universe we
have the exploration of the universe by
spacecraft or whatever going out in
physical space we also have the
exploration of the universe in rule
space and that's kind of the the
different minds and different ways of
describing the universe represent kind
of travel through real space and just as
we kind of you know when we send out
spacecraft and physical space we're
exploring different parts of the
physical Universe when we come up with
different ways of thinking about things
and different ideas we're kind of
traveling in real space and that's kind
of a way to start representing those
kinds of things
all right I'm going to ask a number of
questions that will no doubt put me at
risk of embarrassing myself but I knew
that when I I have to say one more thing
because you were asking about languages
and you were asking about different
human languages that's an example of
being in different places in Royal space
so you can imagine two languages where
the where the kind of the way of
thinking about the world is very similar
they are kind of correspond to nearby
places in Royal space so it's pretty
easy to to translate to travel from one
to the other whereas things which are
very different very different sort of
views of the world are further away in
real space and that's just a way of
perhaps conceptualizing what this thing
is about please go ahead when you said
that I was just thinking about gendered
languages versus ungendered languages
where certain languages that don't
conjugate say past tense like Chinese
Mandarin and how that affects maybe
where you stand in rural space so
how does a branching mind perceive a
branching universe or the branching
might perceiving the branching Universe
I think as many people hear this they
imagine
these multiple or infinite possibilities
branching out in some form of
to conjure the image of the Eddy
so these these changing atoms but if you
took a snapshot of the entity minute
after minute it would have some
resemblance but there is a branching
that I think for many folks listening
will take place in linear time and so
there's some past to Future to this
branching I have tried to stretch my
the boundaries of of how I consider or
Define Time by reading and listening to
say Carlo ravelli who I think focuses a
fair amount of quantum gravity I I don't
know his research very well
how do you think about time is uh is how
humans experience or think about time
just a very
convenient Collective delusion in terms
of its linear past to Future nature
first thing is what is time exactly
that's something that I think we really
kind of nailed and and the way we think
about how Theory of physics I mean time
is the inexorable progress of
computation so in other words the
universe is in some state
then the universe is going to be
transformed to another state
and another one that Progressive process
of transformation is the passage of time
and this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that I was mentioning
before that you kind of Can't Jump Ahead
that is the fact that time is Meaningful
there is something you can't just say oh
I didn't have to go through those
moments of time I could always just jump
ahead now in most of the universe time
is just progressing it's just as the
universe is sort of updated so that
corresponds to the passage of time now
now we are part of the universe so we're
being updated too if the universe just
stopped we wouldn't know it had stopped
because we'd be stopped too so for
example one place where that happens in
the simplest kind of black hole at the
center of the simplest kind of black
hole is a space-time singularity
which has the property that it's a place
where time stops and so in our model of
physics what's happening is this
universe being updated this network is
being updated it's being updated but if
you're at the center of the black hole
it just stops there's no more update
that can be applied
it's like actually if you're doing math
you kind of want to get to that point if
you're doing a calculation you do oh
we're calculating these things are
happening and eventually you get to the
answer and that's a place where it's
fixed nothing changes anymore that's
what happens at the center of the black
hole it's kind of bad news in a sense if
you want to have a future so to speak
because time just stopped and uh you
know so time as far as I'm concerned is
this inexorable progress of computation
and the time is in the actual way that
it manifests in the universe has many
complicated features so for example
you know and relativity and gravitation
Theory and so on there are all kinds of
ways in which the notion of when's at
the same time as somewhere else is
complicated like we say you know let's
say we have a Mars colony one day and we
Define you know Earth Standard Time okay
it's it's 12 noon at this point well
it's 20 light minutes away to Mars for
example do we say that the 12 noon is
the time when the light signal from our
clock that said it was 12 noon on Earth
reaches Mars or do we try and sort of
back calculate that and say well it's
the time when you know it would have
reached if the clock had been 20 minutes
early and so on that whole question of
sort of the way in which you put these
slices Across the Universe to Define
what counts as simultaneity in time
that's kind of the story of Relativity
Theory and gravitation Theory and so on
and uh that's a that's another kind of
twist in this whole thing but in quantum
mechanics the big issue is is there just
one thread of time or are there many
threads of time now we humans normally
only perceive one thread of time I've
sort of wondered whether there's some
you know some trance that people can go
into that's kind of a multi-way trance
where where they actually have multiple
threads of experience that that are
going on at the same time but for most
of us most of the time it's just there's
a you know there's a definite thread of
experience that we have if I mean to
represent what what prompted that Wonder
or question about whether there are
people one of the features of kind of
our model of physics is what ultimately
drives the mathematical structure of
quantum mechanics is this assumption
that we have that we are persistent in
time and that we can conflate things to
the point where we have a single thread
of experience
if that isn't the case then we've got a
different theory of quantum mechanics
because quantum mechanics ends up being
something which says you do all this
quantum mechanical stuff it has these
many paths of history but in the end we
want to get an answer we don't want to
be saying we've got two different
answers in mind we've got to say we say
a definite thing happened
and so you know for example when people
talk about making quantum computers the
big thing that one hopes for is that one
can use these multiple threads of
History to each run a different
computation and so then you can do all
these things in parallel now the big
problem and again I I simply mentioned
dick Feynman too much here but but uh
doesn't bother me he and I worked on
quantum computers back in 1981 or so and
it was kind of a funny experience
because he did all his calculation by
hand and I was using a computer I
actually found one of the one of the
computations that I did from that just
recently and you know he would do these
calculations by hand that I had no idea
why the answers he got were right
because it's just like you do this
calculation and it's like you could have
done this or this or this you could have
made this or this assumption at this
point I don't know why that assumption
is right and he'd look at the stuff I
did on a computer and he'd say I have no
idea why and if that's right
so it was an interesting challenge so to
speak but but actually even at that time
we we kind of concluded that the big
question about sort of making use of
quantum mechanics to compute things is
how do you determine the answer in the
formal theory of quantum mechanics it's
how does the measurement work in quantum
mechanics how do you actually measure
what happened in the quantum process
well now what we see is that all these
threads of history and at the end us
humans if we want to get a deaf and
answer have to knit together all those
threads of history and the big question
is how hard is it to knit together those
threads of history and if it's as hard
to knit them together as what you gain
by having multiple threads then you
don't get an advantage in the end and
that's a that's a difficult thing to
figure out and you know it's something
we're trying to figure out I'm not
hopeful about the true Quantum Advantage
I think that the formalism of quantum
mechanics is super interesting and you
know it's very this whole idea of of
this what we call multi-way graphs and
this whole multiple threads of history
and so on that's a very interesting
formal thing where relevant to many
fields but this idea that you're
actually going to be able to make an
engineering system out of it and get
this sort of quantum Advantage less
convincing it's also as a practical
matter you know the whole Quantum
Computing effort has caused people to
think oh can we make computers out of
things other than electronics and
semiconductors and so on and that's a
completely worthwhile thing as well so
the two ends are worthwhile I'm not sure
that the thing in the middle is so
worthwhile so that's our notion of time
now in terms of people's perception of
time
you know it is this process of you know
we are undergoing these computations our
minds are undergoing these computations
are and so is the rest of the universe
and that's kind of it's the alignment of
the computations going on in our minds
with the computation going on in the
universe that leads these different
forms of time like the time and
thermodynamics of of things sort of
decaying down to Heat or the time in the
expansion of the universe things you
know things about cosmology and so on
the fact that all those different arrows
of time align is a consequence of the
fact that they're actually the same
thing they're all just the sort of
inexorable process of computation that's
happening in the universe
I'm going to use a term that is might be
frustratingly
undefined overused to the point that
it's often undefined at least but I'm
going to ask this question anyway which
is
do you have any thoughts on
what constitutes Consciousness it can be
defined any way you want or it can just
be tossed
or if that is an emergent
Properties or subjective experience with
certain underpinnings it can be
currently explained how do you think
about if at all this may be a terrible
question yeah yeah well I've always sort
of avoided it because I've it's always
seemed like a deeply slippery thing but
yeah I was recently kind of confronted
with I need to apply the idea of
Consciousness I may not have to and
here's how
in the universe ultimately there are all
these possible computations that can
happen
and but our minds don't do all possible
computations our minds they're much more
filtered in what they do and in
particular
they have these features of
computational boundedness belief and
persistence and so on and I think these
are for me those are the things we need
to use about Consciousness to derive
things in physics so those are features
of Consciousness that distinguish us
from the rest of the universe it's kind
of actually a little disappointing
because we might have thought oh there's
you know inanimate matter and there's
this and that and we've got this big
stack we're building that goes through
life and eventually we get intelligence
Consciousness we are the tippy top you
know we are the best thing in the
universe so to speak but actually what
I've come to realize is that that that's
not true at all that the Universe has
much more capability than we have and
this thing we call Consciousness is a
filtering of that capability to
something specific where we believe for
example that there's a single thread of
experience that we have and that that's
kind of the the thing that that
Consciousness the sort of the
application of Consciousness to science
is this thing where it's not about
everything in the universe it's just
about the particular things that are our
sort of the way that our minds perceive
things people talk about well how can
you talk about this and this current
very materialistic way and isn't there
some magic thing in Consciousness that
is this sort of spark that is different
from everything else in the universe
well to us inside there absolutely is to
us inside we are this one point in real
space where there is this set of things
going on that is our experience of the
universe and it's completely unique and
you know there may be some other point
in real space some other mind that is
fairly close by where we can say we're
experiencing these things we can tell
that they're similar to what's being
experienced here but each sort of
Consciousness is is unique in that sense
now you know I was kind of doing an
exercise recently which I need to finish
which is to kind of describe what it's
like to be a computer
and you imagine we humans you know we
live our lives we remember a bunch of
stuff through our lives eventually it's
all lost when we die
and uh the question is for a computer
from the time it boots up to the time
the operating system crashes that's a
period of time over which the computer
has sort of its life experiences and how
do those life experiences compare to the
quotes life experiences that we humans
have you know there is a kind of a whole
sort of inner thinking that's going on
for the computer how does that compare
with us humans there's sort of the
communication with other computers the
the experience of the outside world and
so on you know how does that compare how
can we describe that in uh what it's
what it's like to be even a current
computer forget sort of the science
fiction AI of the future just talk about
a current computer what would it be like
to be the the sort of inside that
experiencing things from the point of
view of of the machine so to speak
let's segue to personal productivity so
this is something I imagine you do still
think about a fair amount and I've read
a fair amount of writing on personal
infrastructure hacks and so on and
it seems like there are
as I think you might describe them nerdy
productivity hacks that then
later become more mainstream or more
accepted more widely distributed are
there any
personal productivity or infrastructure
tools or hacks that you are using now
that you think will gain more adoption
in some form in the not so distant
future
I started live streaming a bunch of
sort of working meetings that I do
and started this about when was it 2017.
um so a few years ago
and
it's really an interesting process
because you know a large fraction of
software design reviews that we do are
live streamed
and that means
you know people who are in the meeting
are a little bit more paying attention
because they kind of know it's going out
to the world but it's also really nice
because there's kind of an immediate
feedback we'll get you know if we
announce some particular topic we're
going to work on we'll get some World
experts in that topic often will show up
because gosh they know they're going to
be stuck using our tools and they might
as well contribute to getting them to be
designed right and also people who are
just energetic users of our technology
and it's really a wonderful kind of
immediate feedback and I think it's to
me
it helps me feel that the time I'm
spending doing you know very detailed
grinding away trying to figure out how
software should be designed and so on it
it feels like the fact that I'm leaving
some record of this feels like it makes
it more meaningful I know people have
used some of our live streams for
software engineering classes and things
like this and so it's you know it helps
me make it seem more meaningful so to
speak I think I've been doing the even
more extreme version of that is that
I've been doing video Work logs which
means I'm just sitting by myself and I'm
working on something and I'm writing
some you know some document or something
like that and I just record it and you
know I like last night I probably
recorded five hours of video Work logs I
basically was working on this sort of
personal Journey history thing and I'm
recording my screen and I'm just
recording what I'm doing now you know
why am I doing this because it's easy to
do and somehow it makes it feel a little
bit more meaningful to me it sort of
makes me think oh I'm not going to goof
off in that way because I'm screen
recording everything uh okay I admit I
have a secondary screen so I can do that
on the second new screen
but uh
and the other thing is when I'm doing
science stuff
what has happened a number of times is
people say well how did you figure that
out I'm saying you can really find out
how I figured that out just go look at
this video just watch it and you can
find the minute where I figured this out
and maybe I got it wrong and you'll see
look you know he did something really
stupid there and you can see that moment
and you can then unwind it same thing by
the way for our
software design meetings the people who
do project management routinely go back
and look at you know all kinds of pieces
of the meetings what actually happened
how do we decide this oh you know a bug
showed up there let's let's go carve
that piece of the video out and and send
it to people and so on you know I think
this thing about doing sort of uh actual
sort of production meetings so to speak
live streamed is I don't know anybody
else who does that I think nobody else
is crazy enough to do it and uh you know
part of why we can do it is that we're
in a unique place and sort of Technology
space where it's not like I mean I know
people who wanted to compete with us at
watch live streams it's like good luck
you know just 35 years building all this
stuff one live stream is not going to
let you rebuild that Tower so you know
that's one thing the other thing that I
myself have become sort of confident
enough that even though I know I'm Gonna
Make You Know say really stupid things
on these live streams I don't care yeah
these are sort of real life things where
yes I'm going to make mistakes people
are going to say you're wrong you're
wrong and we're going to have a little
argument and eventually I'm going to say
hey okay you're right and I don't have a
internal sort of ego issue with either
that process happening or that being
something that people can go back and
find it I'm sure I'm sure it's possible
to find all kinds of terrible stupid
things that I said in these live streams
and so on another okay so another
productivity hack I suppose related to
live streaming is this
so I've also been doing at the beginning
of the pandemic I thought oh all these
kids are going to be out of school I
know a bunch of stuff about science
every so often I'll do a q a you know
once a week I'll do a q a about Science
and Tech for kids and others so I
started doing this at the beginning of
the pandemic and I've still been doing
it I've done 100 episodes or more now of
this you know hour hour and a half on
Fridays of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others okay so what has
that done for me well people ask all
kinds of crazy things and it makes me
think about stuff and I find that this
process of I'm just you know sitting
here looking at the camera and no notes
no looking anything up just how can I
figure out the answer to that question
a couple of days ago there was a
question somebody asked that made me
realize some piece of physics that is
relevant to our physics project that I'd
never realized before and the process of
explaining it particularly with the
forced feature that it just I'm just
going to go on talking at the camera so
to speak it's that forcing function of
so now you know you've got to figure
something out I found really useful for
understanding things and I've been doing
actually two other alternating alternate
weeks q a is one about history of
Science and Technology
and the other about business Innovation
and managing life more your kind of
territory
again I just find it really helpful in
crystallizing my own thinking that I'm
trying to answer these questions
particularly in this real-time format
where I don't get to kind of say oh let
me think about that and let me think
some more about it and so on and then I
never get around to answering it I'm
kind of on the spot and you know having
to answer something and that's been a
very useful process I know that um in
terms of explaining things like science
kinds of things I'm pretty sure I can
feel that I've gotten better through you
know hundreds of hours of people ask
random questions and I try and answer
them the one thing that always trips me
up is when somebody asks a question and
I think to myself that's really easy I
have that one absolutely nailed those
are the ones that I trip up on and
actually there's a serious reason which
I did realize about that which is a lot
of these things where it's like I've
understood that since I was 12 years old
and it's like so it's easy and I realize
oh my gosh it relies on this thing and
that thing and the other thing which I I
learned when I was you know 12 13 years
old or something but not everybody knows
that and I have to go explain that and
then I have to go explain this other
thing that I thought was obvious and
pretty soon once once sort of descending
into this swamp of complicated stuff
let's look at maybe some of the
if there is a there we'll find out
so the physiological underpinnings of
productivity so we have these physical
bodies and you seem to this could just
be my perception but have
energy reserves I'm not using energy in
a very precise physics way but more in a
metabolic way right like you're
producing enough neurotransmitters and
uh you store enough glycogen and so on
that you are able to maintain a very
high
seems like a very high rate of output do
you think about energy management in
that context
or is that something that just comes so
naturally out of the box that you just
have that advantage and you don't have
to think about it
I think I'm lucky that I'm fairly
energetic it's always amusing to me that
you know I'm an old guy now and you know
I can I can sort of out-energize you
know lots of young folk who are working
with me and so on actually I get a kick
out of being able to do that so yeah why
not that helps add energy to the whole
to the whole picture but no I think
one thing is that I do things that I
like to do and for me that's a that's a
huge energizing Force I mean if I was
like oh gosh I have to do this and I
don't really want to do it and I'm not
very interested and it's like you know
I'm jumping into things where I really
want to do this
okay another strange thing I just did I
seem to have been reliving My Life 50
years ago and those last few weeks
because I I had just I
decided to organize a couple of months
ago I initiated this a reunion for my
Elementary School graduating class which
was 1972. small sort of subbloom people
and so it's kind of the 50-year
follow-up it was a little actually it
was you know I liked these people 50
years ago I liked them 50 years later
that was nice but uh
I realized you know one of the things
that's a little disappointing is some
fraction of these people were like the
writing little blurbs about what we've
been doing and they're like I retired I
retired et cetera et cetera et cetera
and they're British folk so they had
lots of witty things to say about you
know what they were doing in their
retirement but so I was realizing well
I'm not retired and I'm not even
and I realized I've been working more
than 12 hours a day every day but
basically all of the last 50 years and
I'm having a good time you know I've
been lucky enough to be able to mostly
do things that sort of add energy to me
rather than taking it away I mean the
things you know when you do when I do
creative kinds of things and I figure
stuff out and even write things and so
on the process of like finishing them
and getting them done is energizing to
me and I think that's you know if if I
was doing things where I'm like
oh I don't know back in back in the day
before before we realized this just
didn't work I would occasionally go
shopping with my wife okay long ago and
I would try and take my wife to science
museums okay so my wife is a
mathematician so the science museums are
not so far away but they're far enough
away that that she's like oh I'm getting
so tired walking around the science
museum so for me it would have a
physiological effect on me going around
looking around shops you know I'm like I
feel really tired you know I have to I
have to kind of looking at things
et
cetera
um I think the effect that I'm doing
things I really want to be doing is an
important effect now you know having
said that I I did discover when I was
kind of like 40 years old hey you should
do some exercise and that helped for me
I think add a bunch of energy I mean I
for the last three years I've I've
walked more than ten thousand steps
every single day for the last three
years and that's kind of just one of my
AI constraints even if I'm traveling or
this or that or the other it's kind of
like the people who schedule stuff for
me it's like I gotta walk 10 000 steps
if that's around an airport on phone
calls and things so be it but I'm just
gonna that's a constraint on my life so
to speak
and you know I think that has had a
positive effect for me it's kind of been
bizarre because
when I was younger I wasn't in terribly
good shape I'm in better shape now and
so for me I don't yet notice that I'm
aging because I'm actually better off in
many ways than I was when I was younger
yeah your mitochondria are getting
younger than anything another thing
about that and about sort of the the
management of one's life and so on I
mean I've been fortunate enough that
often you'll do something and maybe you
do something really cool when you're 25
years old and then kind of it's all
downhill from there it's hard to get
motivated and I've been lucky enough
that well for example this physics
project that just sort of arrived three
years ago that was something I didn't
really expect it's a rejuvenating kind
of thing and it's just added a lot of
energy to my you know it's just so many
things to think about and so on yeah
that's one thing I sleep as close to
eight hours as I can you know I don't
try and sort of game it saying I'm going
to try and shave off extra time and so
on I'm very habitual and in terms of
when I go to sleep when I wake up things
I eat tend to be habitual they may not
be optimal but they're habitual at least
you know I've found that um for me I try
and sort of optimize away all those
aspects of my life that I really don't
care about so to speak that I don't um
you know keep those as sort of simple
and not having to think about them as
possible so that I can sort of spend my
thinking effort on things where I really
want to think about these things yeah
and I really want to spend my time on
them so I've been fortunate enough that
for whatever reason the mitochondria are
still alive and kicking and providing
good energy but I think it's mostly that
just doing things that I want to do and
also you know I tend to organize it so
that okay there are things that I save
up for I'm going to do this if I'm
feeling tired and sometimes I have a
another set of things I'm going to do
this if I if I get sick
okay and I've had a whole bunch of those
and I've only I've only been sick once
in the last three years so I haven't
didn't have a chance to I've got this
big pent-up supply of things to do when
I'm sick now are those just low energy
low interest tasks that nonetheless kind
of have to get done like yeah talk to my
accountant about XYZ whatever something
like that well they're not usually
talking to other people they're usually
organizing informational kinds of things
well sometimes the watch this video that
I've been meaning to watch and have
never had time to do
yeah but uh you know I did I did learn
okay so this is one not yet very
scientific hack fact okay which is
I was curious what has caused me to get
sick when I've gotten sick why have I
gotten sick and so I have a data for I
think 27 years maybe of um I think all
the times I've gotten sick it's always
upper respiratory you know things right
and so I think I've gotten sick 25 times
in 27 years and the question is what was
I doing when I got sick and was it you
know oh I went out and I met a bunch of
people or was it whatever and the one
correlation and I haven't been
completely scientific about this the one
correlation has was it was often two
days after I was on a flight on a plane
yeah and in a few cases that was not a
commercial plane that was a private
plane so it without a lot of other
people on it yeah and so it's kind of
interesting and so then I asked my
medical research friends and so on hey
what's going on here and here's the
theory the theory would be you know a
big part of upper respiratory defense so
to speak is the innate immune system
operating like in one's nose and so on
and if you get your nose dried out and
so on from being in the you know dry air
and on planes and things like that your
little innate immune system doesn't
stand a chance
so my my hack has been take things like
wheat germ and so on that stimulate um
just before I go on a plane take that
and a couple of other things and so far
we only have an N of about eight or
something of trips I've done so far I
haven't gotten sick so far so good
well it also makes me think of ways that
you could
they're not necessarily humidify but
maintain the sort of moisture Integrity
of the Sino lining as well with a spray
or something like that yeah I thought
about that my most relevant medical
research friend claimed it's easier to
just take choline than it is to try and
do that try to keep the nose well
hydrated it's kind of a strange thing
you know you're on some flight going
somewhere and you're like continually
having things or whatever
but you know one of the things I found
that that for me it's like keep the list
of things to do when I'm tired because
for me in terms of motivation and so on
it's always nice you know like if I'm
sick I might be like oh my gosh I'm sick
I'm so that's so terrible but in a sense
I'm like great now I have a chance to do
these things I knew I had to do so I do
the same thing when I'm driving places
you know I always maintain a call while
driving list you know phone calls that
are slightly more you know I've got to
do this sometime I don't need to be in
front of a computer
this is something I can do then it's
actually good for lots of kinds of
interactions that I do where I I kind of
wouldn't I'd never get around to it it's
just like you know if there's a person
who lives in the same city that you do
you never see them but if they live
somewhere completely different you know
oh I'm coming to wherever for a day and
you end up seeing them and it's been
kind of the same thing for me with cool
while driving it's like well I'm going
to call somebody and so you know this is
that process
well Stephen I'm so continually
impressed with
not just the breadth of your thinking
but how you log and track and interpret
so much
data I mean I think that I take a lot of
notes but you mentioned at the top of
this conversation a quarter million
Pages something along those lines it's
just incredible that's the stuff on
paper actually I have three million
emails as well so yeah a lot of stuff
over a long period of time so a lot of
stuff over a long period of time and I
would love to at some point do a round
two we could do themed conversations on
probably several dozen different topics
is there anything else that you would
like to mention in this conversation or
call my audience's attention to oh my
anything at all in terms of closing
remarks comments any grievances you'd
like to air publicly uh anything at all
that you'd like to mention before we
makes me want to ask you for a bunch of
personal productivity hacks and so on
and what am I missing type thing because
that's that's always you know one slowly
accumulates these things and I find you
know I'll try things and probably
two-thirds of the things I try work and
one third don't but I want to keep
trying them anyway so yeah I think no
we've covered all kinds of things I look
forward to hopefully seeing you again in
person at some point but this has been
delightful and very fun for me I've
taken copious notes so I will be doing
lots of follow-up on my own and you seem
to be doing pretty well on the
productivity side if I think of anything
that is a gross a mission I will be sure
to send it to you people can find you on
Twitter Stephen that's a pH Stephen
underscore well from then facebook slash
Stephen Wolfe from linkedin.com also
your name and then the website Stephen
wolfram.com and we'll link to everything
that you've mentioned is there anything
that you would like to point people to
that is top of mind for you at the
moment
or any resources that people may not
find on their own the stuff I write ends
up in
writings.stevenwolfen.com and I put lots
of effort into writing these things so
hopefully some people find them fun to
read although even the process of
writing them as I was explaining is a
useful process in its own right there's
also a recent thing for me as we just
launched our Wolfram Institute which is
a um
that's kind of a I suppose a an
attempted productivity hack you know I
my company which I started now 36 years
ago is kind of my machine for turning
ideas that I have into real things and
it's you know it's 800 people who are
really really good at doing that
and coming up with their own ideas as
well but that's been a thing where we
mostly we make products but one of the
problems I've been trying to solve is if
you're making basic science what's the
machine that does that and I've sort of
carved off a bit of resources from the
company and so on to do it but we just
just recently launched Wolfman Institute
which is a thing whose goal is to do
basic science and that's kind of a new
thing in the last just few weeks
so stay tuned for interesting things
that are happening there and I guess um
there'll be more yet more live streaming
of Science and action and so on there so
those are a few things
I suppose the other you know I have to
plug my life work
my life work is building more from
language and Wolfman Alpha and
Mathematica and so on which are all part
of the same idea of sort of make the
world computational and I suppose the
the one sort of pitch I would I would
make is what we've built I can
inexorably see is an artifact from the
future in other words the direction that
things are going in is going in this
direction of representing the world
computationally and being able to really
make use of that but you know there are
a few million people who actually do
make use of it in our technology stack
but there are a lot of millions of
people who don't and you know this is
sort of an inexorable piece of the
future and it's a big Advantage if you
can kind of grab the magic from the
future you know I've taken to a lot of
work with kids
who are learning our stuff and doing
projects and so on and I've taken to
referring to you know learning
computational language is a superpower
you get to do that and then you can do
all kinds of magic things with it learn
that superpower yeah more people should
do it and it's it's one of these things
where you can kind of see in in the
world
when things involve sort of Big Ideas
there's a certain inexorable slowness to
the way that they get adopted and there
are always some some number of early
adopters who you know are the ones that
run out in front
so my parting pitch would be you know if
you don't understand computational
language in modern language and so on
try to understand it because it is it is
for me the you know you talk about
productivity hacks
the biggest amplifier hugest
productivity hack is the whole
computational language idea that's what
you know all the things I've done in
science and in technology they kind of
are all based on that idea and the kind
of tower of technology that we built
around that so that's my that's my kind
of parting ultimate productivity hack
wonderful and it's for everybody
listening Mathematica wolf from alpha
Wolfram language we will link to all of
these things in the show notes at timed
out Blog podcast and you can just search
Wolfram
w-o-l-f-r-a-m and that will pop right up
uh Stephen I really enjoy
learning from you because you're not
only an incredible
thinker technologist I'm sure there are
many multi-hyphenate labels I could
apply but you're a very gifted
communicator and teacher so the
practical impact of what you do is not
just manifested through the products
used by millions of people and that will
be used in some form or another by many
many millions more but also in the
principled and systematic thinking that
you can share and do share with people
including including kids including with
non-technical Muggles who are
nonetheless very curious like myself and
no doubt with many many millions of
listeners on this podcast so thank you I
really really appreciate the time you
you take to do what you do and the time
you've also taken to have this
conversation so thank you thank you very
much and uh to everybody listening I'll
play it one more time you can go to
tim.blog podcast for the show notes for
all things we've mentioned in this
episode and in all episodes and until
next time be a little bit Kinder than is
necessary
be very curious
definitely paddle early for the
superpowers that you can get ahead of in
terms of early adoption like those that
Stephen was mentioning and thank you for
tuning in